il est temps d'agir il est temps de
décider
cette déclaration du 10 juillet du
président du conseil européen charles
michel résonnait encore en pleine après
tractations ce week end à bruxelles
à l'origine un plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros à l'initiative du
couple franco-allemand et j'ai retrouvé
en gala merkel pour avancer sur le plan
de relance européen que nous portons
ensemble
ce plan va permettre de surmonter la
crise économique et sociale que nous
traversons
l'europe en a besoin notre objectif est
simple mobiliser au moins 500 milliards
d'euros de subventions tourner vers les
régions les plus touchées
pour réussir nous devons obtenir un
accord à vingt-sept lors du prochain
conseil européen de mi juillet nous
allons poursuivre les négociations et
tout faire pour convaincre nos
partenaires problème quatre états
s'oppose fermement à cette opération
qu'ils jugent déséquilibrée pays bas
autriche danemark et suède alias les
frigos ou encore les radins de l'union
européenne comme ils sont surnommés par
leurs détracteurs ont bien des raisons
de s'opposer aux modalités de ce week
aubry found s'il ne rejette pas le prêt
de 250 milliards d'euros ils remettent
en question la mutualisation de la dette
à hauteur elle de 500 milliards le club
des 4 se dit prête à venir en aide aux
voisins les plus touchés par la crise du
coronavirus tels que l'italie ou encore
l'espagne condition sinequanone des
prêts et non des subventions comme
réclamée par paris et berlin
alors pourquoi une telle résistance tout
d'abord leur taux d'endettement est
parmi les plus faibles de l'union euros
autre argument ils sont contributeurs
nets au budget de l'union européenne
traduction ils donnent plus qu'ils ne
reçoivent marque route
le premier ministre néerlandais chef de
file des frigos souhaite un vote à
l'unanimité à chaque fois qu'une tranche
d'argent devra être débloqués
mais ces pays sont ils réellement les
moins endettés de l'union européenne
sont ils les seuls contributeurs nets de
la zone pas si sûr que ça car les taux
d'endettement privé danois et
néerlandais sont parmi les plus élevés
au monde due notamment à la dette des
ménages qui dépasse largement celle de
la grèce par exemple concernant leur
statut de contributeurs nets qu'il met
en avant il semblerait que vienne
amsterdam copenhague stockholm ne soient
pas les seuls de l'ue à rome et au même
titre contributeurs nets et sa
contribution à l'union européenne en
2018 était bien plus importante
dernier point mais pas des moindres
trois de ces quatre pays bénéficient de
rabais dans le cadre pluriannuel de
l'union euros le rabais c'est ce
mécanisme de correction du budget
européen qui consiste en un accord entre
l'union européenne et certains de ses
états membres qui les exemples
partiellement de contribuer on l'aura
compris une sphère tendues à bruxelles
ce week-end sur fond de divergences et
de crispation de groupes qui vont devoir
trouver très vite un terrain d'entente
afin de sortir de ces négociations qui
s'enlise et illustre une nouvelle fois
l'impasse d'une union européenne qui
n'en a plus guère que le nom agir et
décider comme l'appelait de ses voeux
charles michel n'est ce pas au fond un
jeu de consensus et de compromis qui
pour certains experts pourrait marquer
le déclin d'une union européenne déjà
bien fragilisé
il y a décidément de petites économies
qui peuvent s'avérer très coûteuse sur
la durée